finally pregnant kerry washington talks  getting back to scandal I mean really  lucky because the people that I work  with I love them dearly filming season  six with baby number two on the way has  its unique challenges Carrie tells the  new in style there's nothing high end  for professional women who are pregnant  but she makes do with a box of maternity  clothes that she Jessica Alba and other  star mom's passed back and forth quote  you're less afraid to spend money  because you feel that a lot of people  are going to use it you know it's like  The Sisterhood of the Traveling  maternity club who let me just say this  Olivia Pope carries alter ego would  never share her maternity clothes  abba-abba-abba  you